in this segment we start a new topic we
will talk about the covariance of two
random variables which gives us useful
information about the dependencies
between these two random variables let
us motivate the concept by looking first
the special case suppose that x and y
have zero means and that they are
discrete random variables if x and y are
independent then the expectation of the
product is the product of the
expectations and since we have assumed
zero means this is going to be equal to
zero but suppose instead that the joint
PMF of the x and y is of the following
kind each point in this diagram is
equally likely so we have here a
discrete uniform distribution on the
discrete set which consists of the
points shown in this diagram what we
have in this particular example is that
that most outcomes positive values of X
tend to go together with positive values
of Y and negative values of X tend to go
together with negative values of Y so
most of the time we have outcomes in
this quadrant in which x times y is
positive or in this quadrant where x
times y is again positive but some of
the time we fall in this quadrant when
an x times y is negative or in this
quadrant where x times y is negative
since we have many more points here and
here
on the average the value of x times y is
going to be positive on the other hand
if the diagram takes this form then most
of the time the pair XY lies in this
quadrant or in that quadrant where the
product of x times y is negative so the
random variables x and y typically have
opposite signs and on the average the
expected value of x times y is going to
be negative so here we have a positive
expectation here we have a negative
expectation of x times y this quantity
the expected value of x times y tells us
whether x and y tend to move in the same
or in opposite directions and this
quantity is what we call the covariance
in the zero mean case let us now
generalize the random variables do not
have to be discrete
this quantity is well defined for any
kind of random variables and if we have
non zero means the covariance is defined
by this expression what we have here is
that we look at the deviation of X from
its mean value and the deviation of Y
from its mean value and we are asking
whether these two deviations tend to
have the same sign or not whether they
move in the same direction or not if the
covariance is positive what it tells us
is that whenever this quantity is
positive so that X is above its mean
then typically or usually the deviation
of Y from its mean will also tend to be
positive to summarize the covariance in
general tells us whether two random
variables tend to move together both
being high or both being low in sum
average or typical sense now if the two
random variables are independent we
already saw that in the zero mean case
this quantity the covariance is going to
be zero how about the case where we have
nonzero means well if we have
independence then we have the expected
value of the product of two random
variables x and y are independent so X
minus the expected value which is a
constant is going to be independent from
Y minus its expected value and so the
covariance is going to be the product of
two expectations
but the expected value of X minus this
constant is zero and the same is true
for this term as well so the covariance
in this case is going to be equal to
zero so in the independent case we have
zero covariances on the other hand the
converse is not true there are examples
in which we have dependence but zero
covariance here is one example in this
example there are four possible outcomes
at at any particular outcome either X or
Y is going to be zero so in this example
the random variable x times y is
identically equal to 0 the mean of X is
also 0 the mean of Y is also 0 by
symmetry so the covariance is the
expected value of this quantity and so
the covariance in this example is equal
to 0 on the other hand the two random
variables x and y are dependent if I
tell you that X is equal to 1 then you
know that this outcome has occurred and
in that case you are certain that Y is
equal to 0 so knowing the value of X
tells you a lot about the value of Y and
therefore we have dependence between
these two random variables